bienvenue dans paf l'émission
décortiquent l'actualité au parlera
cette semaine de prélèvement à la source
on parlera du code du travail on parlera
du baccalauréat de l'article 49 3 on
reviendra aussi sur le droit du sol et
du droit du sang enfin un sommaire très
chargé pour en parler florence berck à
des chocs et bonjour avocat au barreau
de versailles
jean-luc madec toujours la commanderie
avec un grand projet on en parlera d'ici
quelques semaines et je lui devais pas à
décortiquer
absolument mustapha larbaoui qui a lancé
l'appel du 17 juin le 16 juin du sas du
labrador
cette semaine on n'en dira peut-être un
beau tout à l'heure quand même pas son
nom c'est parti
c est jean charles lajoie dix éditeurs
l'auteur heureux puisque c'est très bien
voilà en gros donc beaucoup de beaucoup
de sujets cette semaine on peut
commencer par bath qui fait débat le la
peau l'impôt et l'impôt sur le revenu
notamment avec le prélèvement à la
source qui est ça y est actée ça sera
pour 2018
il y aura une année blanche en 2010 est
qu'ils ont sera pas vraiment rude parce
qu'on passera directement de 2016 et
2018 ça vous intéresse ou post afin de
vous en fichez je pense non moi je m'en
fiche
absolument pas parce que je suis
concernée comme une grande majorité des
français on est concerné par l'impôt
concernés va concerner une grande partie
grande partie voire même celles qui n'en
payent pas en rêverait puisque après
tout il ya ceux qui ont pas aidé environ
20 euros
ce qui n'empêche pas d'ailleurs au
passage on dit toujours que n'est pas
normal que des gens ne payent par les
gros auquel cas peut-être que s'il
gagnait autrement leur vie ils ont pas
mise en péril par centaines ils en
rêvent mais c'est pas la question ouais
non moi je suis bien sûr je me sens
intéressé puisque je serai concernés ce
qui m'intéresse c'est le débat autour de
la construction de cette idée c'est à
dire que de ce que j'ai compris la
france n'est pas le seul pays concerné
il ya d'autres pays qui le font déjà le
fournit des caméras ou l'un des rares
hommes appliquée et finalement la
discussion est en train de tourner
surtout sur les allées à cette mesure
sur la difficulté de la mise en oeuvre
sur voilà toute la problématique
finalement de mise en oeuvre
ça me parait effectivement être très
compliqué il ya une possibilité de faire
ça d'un coup donc ce serait la fameuse
année blanche qui n'en serait pas une
mais ça serait brutale ça serait défi ça
serait pour le coup en une fois certains
pensent le faire de façon progressive le
débat n'est pas tranché le risque est
sûre ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à mon avis
il faut retenir une idée très simple
c'est que là pour le coup on parle de
simplification dans ce pays
la difficulté sera le moment du passage
au prélèvement à la source mais serait
pas racine et surtout un jour accord de
on est vers la simplification la
clarification
alors il y aura effectivement des
difficultés à la mise en oeuvre et puis
probablement une année un peu un peu
charnière mais pont pour ce qui me
concerne bien sûr bien sûr pas pressé
moi je veux franchement je vois pas bien
l'intérêt de ce genre de réforme de la
majorité des français sont mensualisés
donc ils peuvent de toute façon
leurs impôts tous les mois donc il n'ya
pas de vrais soucis
après tout être content c'est pas très
important ça va encore être une usine à
gaz que ça va être compliqué parce que
pour les entreprises ça va quand même
beaucoup de boulot et les entreprises
qui vont donc voilà l'info on peut
beaucoup de monde les sépare est
simplement que pas un seul fonctionnaire
il n'y aura pas un fonctionnaire en
moins alors qu'ils ne font plus le
boulot donc ça s'appelle pas encore une
fois sont là ça va être dégagée des
emplois je pourrais probablement parce
que rire à nantes rôle mais pas du tout
parce que le dira les types qui pour
l'instant collecte l'impôt contrôler
l'eau seront affectés au contrôle les
gens qui collecteront leur place donc on
va multiplier les couches du
millefeuille comme d'habitude
et puis tu vois là et puis honnêtement
choisi le travail qui était fait par
l'administration sera fait ou par les
entreprises
oui bon je suis prêt à parier ce que
vous voulez qu'il y aura pas un seul
poste dégagé et de fonctionnaires
libérés ils sont toujours occupés à la
bonne chose à dire à peu ils sont
toujours en train d'emmener tournée
déborder comme avant tu sais pas c'est
l'éducation c'est de dire voilà chaque
année je sais ce que je gagne je sais ce
que je fais c'est clair c'est à la
source
voilà donc c'est globalement la
simplification qu'on a recherché si
demain il ya par ce biais des économies
à faire
ils seront fin mais c'est pas ce qui a
été épargné la simplification et on
serait les salles finalement avoir
raison peut être probablement ce
probablement en faisant des quelque
chose de compliqué on s'y attaque pas à
leur dire qu'à quelques avec 4 millions
de chômeurs johnny je pense qu'il y
avait des réformes plus importantes à la
stasi sait pas où il s est vu comme un
truc extraordinaire
c'est une réforme des prélèvements selon
m
des finances publiques ça peut être le
préalable à une vraie refonte de l'impôt
parce que du coup les optimistes je
pense qu'on vous n'êtes pas bien à un
iota on est d'accord mais ça peut être
le préalable effectivement une refonte
des il aurait peut-être fallu commencer
fiscale et ça permettra le nettoyage
plus facilement parce que c'est clair et
c'est automatique
des toits ça c'est compliqué de faire
table rase et passionnante esprits
s'échauffent à périers d'abord je pense
que ce serait le seul défaut de ce point
de vue ici donc en plus ça mais moi je
vais je trouve cela très bien aussi la
seule chose c'est que c'est une annonce
politique alors même que le technique
n'est pas prêt du tout donc là c'est un
premier problème on est aussi
effectivement un des rares pays en
europe à avoir ce prélèvement à la
source sauf que tous les autres pays
sont sûrs de la fiscalité individuelle
alors que nous on est sûr de fiscaliser
du foyer 2 1 donc on a un problème
fiscalité du foyer on apprend selon le
sur cette cérémonie un enfant c'est un
peu compliquer c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué à c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué donc il aurait été avant de
faire la réforme de la collecte il
aurait peut-être fallu faire de la
réforme fiscale
d'abord se prépare à ça et ensuite faire
la réforme de la collecte
donc je pense qu'on a fait les choses un
petit peu à l'envers
sinon je pense que c'est bien mais ça va
effectivement mettre un peu plus de
boulot pour les entreprises qui vont
devoir faire de la collecte à la place
de l'état et dans les autres pays
européens j'ai regardé un petit peu le
problème ça va dégager un seul emploi et
voir même ils ont dû rembauché pour
parce qu'il faut contrôler les
entreprises qui collectent et puis de
toute façon ça empêche pas de faire sa
déclaration fiscale
et puis on n'a pas traité le problème
des commerçants des professions
libérales est ce que ça va être des
acomptes pas d'acompte c'est facile pour
les salariés c'est facile c'est fait
c'est au les salariés et youri ça sera
laissée langues qui sont concernées les
liaisons bassi parce qu'on commence à me
dire tu vas falloir qu'ils payent des
acomptes donc c'est une espèce de
mensualisation
mais sur la base de l'année n moins un
an alors même que ce sont des gens qui
ont des revenus qui sont variables et
qui serait peut-être le plus intéressé à
coller au plus près du revenu que la
maladie
les intérêts de cette réforme c'est
justement de payer des impôts de ce
conte absolue attendez on est sur les
rails mais sur les libéraux et les
commerçants je sais pas bien fait ça et
puis alors leur dernier point sur
l'année blanche et le cadeau fiscal
c'est une grosse blague c'est
effectivement plus que le jeune qui va
commencer à travailler au 1er janvier
2018 il est content il n'a pas tout de
suite des impôts cela étant dit il ya
quand même un point positif c'est que
tous les salariés en 2010 ne seront
aucun salarié ne sera imposée sur ses
revenus 2010 est oui donc c'est quand
même sur ce qu'il gagne en 2010 voilà
donc ça peut être plus rien fait de mal
et voilà payer plus en 2017 alors oui
c'est pour ça que ça existe guère de
secrétaires d'état au budget a dit
qu'ils allaient faire un exploit ce que
justement suivent pas il n'y a pas
d'effets effet de remettre pour livrer
pour les choses comme ça mais en
revanche ça a été fait une année une
année en islande et ça vraiment booster
la croissance que c'est vraiment été les
gens ont compris
je vais pas d'impôts laisse juste année
je l'investis il va descendre donc
septembre oui j'en ai mal et qui la vit
évidemment aussi mais c'est la risle une
douzaine de personnes
ils voient les fiches de paye qui
maintenant font une page entière rempli
parfois même plus évidemment la réforme
est dans les tuyaux depuis une trentaine
d'années ça l'est pour elle c'est déjà
le cas dans une grande partie du pays
des rentes que le prélèvement soit fait
à la source sur les salaires bon
compliqué évidemment ça le sera la
réforme
visiblement va être mise en route ce qui
est tout à fait intéressant c'est ce que
je vous disais il ya quelques semaines
c'est que finalement après trois années
de quasi inaction et de chants aux
bisounours là d'un seul coup le
président dans les salles en espagne et
ne vous a pas échappé que il vous sort
une réforme tous les quinze jours et ça
va continuer jusqu'à mai 2010 est donc
ne soyez pas certain qu'ils seront
impeccables qu'en 2001 entendu mais avec
vous avez lu la le coup formidable tient
quand même dans l'imaginaire public on
entend dire 2010 cette distance rare
souhaite c'est l'année des élections
présidentielles il est aujourd'hui
clairement en campagne et il va vous
sortir qu'une réforme comme ça tous les
quinze jours
par contre la réforme que moi j'attends
c'est la réforme qui a trait au train de
vie de l'état
est ce que dans une seule des réformes
qui vous a été proposé depuis grosso
modo deux mois et parmi celles qui vous
est proposée jusqu'à mai 2017
on parle une seule joie de la réduction
importante qu'il faut faire sur le train
de vie de l'état
non or notre problématique à nous
français réside essentiellement dans
cette question quand allons-nous réduire
réellement le transit de marie pourrait
y avoir aussi d'un forum fiscal il faut
une vraie réforme fiscale avec on en
parle dans la forme mais pas dans le
fond c'est pas la réponse à des
prélèvements sepa le secteur fiscal un
très fort chez les impôts mais pour
baiser des impôts il faut baiser de
cambridge et a donc le nombre de
fonctionnaires en particulier dans la
fonction publique territoriale
c'est là où on a continué de battre des
records
les deux dernières années au fou aux
fous alors moi je suis très contente
d'entendre tout ça c'est bien s'amuse le
peuple moi pas mais en l'occurrence que
j'attends avec une grande impatience
pour ensuite de traduire auprès de mes
amis professionnels
c'est à quel moment va-t-on réduire de
façon spectaculaire le train de vie de
l'état je pense qu'il va attendre un
petit moment
j'avais peur on attendait peur c'est
pour ça que je continue à faire du
syndicalisme est justement pas de vue
puisque vous parlez de syndicalisme la
réforme du code du travail
et voilà aussi un serpent de mer dont on
parle depuis des années alors c'est vrai
que le code du travail est passé de 700
pages à 8000 pages aujourd'hui peut-être
plus 500 articles à huit mille artistes
ils ont averti que les bus bien
l'article
en combien d'années entre 1974 et
aujourd'hui alors 1974 je crois qu'il y
avait sept cent mille chômeurs à peu
près il y en a à peu près 6 millions
cette mini aujourd'hui ça dépend des les
chiffres et certains disent ben oui on
regarde et c'est plus plus le code du
travail s'accroît et plus le chômage
s'accroît
est-ce que vous pensez que jean-luc il
ya un lien entre les deux est rôle
évidemment complexité du droit du
travail pour dire les choses c'est pas
grave on est on est on est là pour en
parler c'est jean-luc moi je vais vous
donner un exemple encore plus précis
nous nous bagarrons dans notre métier
pour essayer de mettre en place une
vraie politique pour les apprentis je
veux les quatre chiffres très très
simple en france nous avons 438 me
l'apprenti toutes activités confondues
430000 apprentis en allemagne un million
cinq cent mille en france nous sommes à
25 % de taux de chômage pour les jeunes
entre 15 et 24 ans en allemagne 5,6 bien
qu est ce qui cause cette
énorme écart entre l'allemagne et la
france et si vous pouvez dans d'autres
pays du nord de l'europe ou bien les
pays anglo saxons on est à la même
proportion
c'est quoi c'est évidemment code du
travail tard qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans un espèce de deux temps
brouillamini darty de code qui fait
d'ailleurs le régal de nos amis avocats
gagnent leur vie avec ça c'est bien
normal et c'est normal qu'ils soient
pour mais en même temps est bon en même
temps il faut casser
il faut casser un système il faut casser
le système il faut que nous puissions en
france 1 re mettre des jeunes au travail
et ça passe en grande partie par
l'apprentissage nous pouvons au moins
multiplié par deux le nombre d'apprentis
s'était passé de 438 mille cinq cent
mille à un million
sans atteindre le million cinq cent
mille de l'allemagne et en même temps
nous pouvons le faire très vite
mais pour ça il faut changer de cap
radicalement alors je ne vois aucune
réforme venir à ce sujet et ça me désole
un mot pardon à sa part le réseau en
tant que chef d'entreprise est ce que
vous avez n'avait pas engagé par exemple
des apprentis ou des salariés à cause de
la complexité du code du travail
videmment clairement oui
clairement il s'est inscrit à
considérable surtout dans mon métier
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans nos métiers pour avoir
un cuisinier un serveur un plongeur une
femme de ménage et l usine à gaz que
c'était pour pouvoir les recrutés sur
des périodes cours plombes pour des
extras que je me sais c'est son très
gros dégâts mais à chaque fois
résultat des courses et bat tout le
monde s'est replié dans sa coquille et
au lieu de créer des richesses
au contraire on a fait disparaître c'est
une folie on marchait un gros marche sur
la tête alors florence puisque vous avez
été maintenir des chocs et puisque vous
avez été mise en cause en tant
qu'avocate l'afa radars mais je le sais
très taquin mais c'est vrai que moi je
défends surtout surtout des entreprises
le code du travail on est bien d'accord
il est il est trop gros il est lisible
il est incompréhensible que je déjeune
accord oui non mais ceux là où je ne
suis pas d'accord
est-ce que celle que des rails qui fait
chômage ou pas c'est la situation
économique pour dénoncer la situation
c'est la situation économique moi je
fréquente
que des entrepreneurs tout comme vous
fréquenter que des entrepreneurs et moi
mes clients ne me dise pas je n'embauche
pas à cause du code du travail les
embauches pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
carnet de commandes ou qui n'ont pas
suffisamment de trésorerie pour assumer
le paiement des salaires et le paiement
des charges sociales ou qu'ils n'ont pas
de visibilité économique
mais dès lors qu'ils ont un carnet de
commandes qui se remplit et qu'ils ont
besoin d'embaucher ils vont embaucher
c'est pas à cause du code du travail
alors le code du travail est devenu
complètement pléthorique illisible c'est
vrai qu'il ya donc on a eu de cette
tribune est le livre qui sort de mes
pairs élus enfants à nantes 1 2 million
camp où ils ont eux mêmes alors que sur
eux-mêmes à l'heure où deux palais voilà
voilà des gens de gauche qui se découvre
en soit le garde des sceaux professeur x
series et est excellent en droit social
donc ils ont essayé de réfléchir un peu
en disant et en faisant le parallèle est
au chômage et où il ya un parallèle
entre le je suis aussi convaincu que ça
parce que vous savez que non plus non
mais je suis d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faut c'est sur l'analyse sur l'analyse
du 2 2 parce que c'est le chômage et le
chômage avec des crochets voilà le
chômage a décollé en 74 ans n'a eu comme
la crise du pétrole
parallèlement le code du travail a
grossi mais je pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'effet et en plus les lois en 1974 et
80 était beaucoup plus drastiques est
beaucoup plus compliqué ne serait-ce que
de licenciement économique manquait
toujours compliqué aujourd'hui mais
avant il fallait demander l'autorisation
à l'inspection du travail c'était
beaucoup plus rigide beaucoup dans les
années il y avait que 800 articles aussi
qu'aujourd'hui on a eu une vie mais
voilà c'est plus haut mais c'est vrai
que ça c'est pas possible d'avoir un
code du travail à huit mille articles il
faut effectivement il faut il faudrait à
mon sens on peut pas le simplifier pour
le mettre à la poubelle et à écrire
autre chose
ce qu'ils disent la seule chose c'est
qu'ils mettent les 50 articles
fondamentaux sur lesquels en fait une
synthèse du code du travail
parce qu'ils suivent la chronologie du
code donc ils font une synthèse en 50
articles très très bien me renvoie à la
loi il renvoie au décret donc je vois
pas et à la négociation que c'est pas un
mal français c'est vouloir tout régler
par la loi par le laisser jouer au
volley à son association des consciences
bush en tentant de préparer le terrain
pour une autre réforme parce que de
toute façon il est clair que le code du
travail doit être réformé alain florence
dire juste titre vous mettre à la
poubelle et or écrit très bien mais il
va ça va prendre du temps donc il faut
de toute façon mais renfermé et que font
et se base d'intérêts monsieur dion
quand il prépare le terrain ce sont
effectivement des consciences de gauche
il faut parce que ça sent le match avec
à gauche et récent la seule partie mais
plein et donc évidemment ils sont en
tout préparé le terrain parce que dans
une des prochaines réformes que va nous
annoncer monsieur au lendemain de son
premier ministre monsieur valls ça va
être de la com du code du travail
la problématique aujourd'hui pour nous
entrepreneurs elle est simple raptiva
mène pour l'instant dit non pas la
facture lamence et c'est lui qui me
lisent pour nous montrer que lui il se
protège des coups comme un crabe il
aurait certes jamais mais il faut
libérer le travail c'est une honte c'est
une évidence
à la question qu'est ce qu'être
d'entreprise par exemple la question
à la question est ce que finalement si
tu connais travail était plus simplifié
ce qui aurait moins de chemin et france
moi je ne crois pas non plus
par contre ça simplifierait peut-être
les rapports entre les employeurs et les
salariés
parce que voilà moi je gère à peu près
20 22 salariés au total
est ce que vous y engager quelques biens
ou là là c'est compliqué en tous les cas
au moment de l'embauché
on a toujours l'impression que les
salariés viennent nous rencontrer et ont
peur de pas être embauchés ont été on a
tout aussi peur que de ne pas pouvoir
les embauches et non plus dire que
finalement la crainte allée des deux
côtés il ya celui qui veut rentrer en
disant j'espère qu'il va me prendre
j'espère j'espère et donc il a peur
d'être rejetés et nous finalement on n'a
qu'une envie c'est d'embaucher et
sénateurs veuillez ne pas se retrouver
qu'un salarié qui pendant trois quatre
cinq ans au regard du droit du travail
dans des files code du travail pourront
éventuellement signer c'est donc
finalement il ya une crainte des dodgers
et ça pourrait juste avoir un effet
psychologique sur les deux parties c'est
seule chose que je vois réellement pour
détendre un petit peu les choses entre
entre les deux parties deuxièmement
c'est très complexe donc ça suppose que
moi je suis constamment à vérifier tout
ce que je dis tout ce que je fais donc à
vérifier par voie d'avocat ou l'expert
comptable
donc c'est vrai que c'est une lourdeur
on va dire mais c'est pas ce qui est le
frein à l'embauché et à l'économie moi
je pense que la france est en cinquième
puissance du monde quand on la compare
avec l'angleterre avec l'allemagne les
etats-unis quand on a des pib par tête
d'habitant filmant la vraie question
c'est quoi c'est le choix de société la
france décide d'avoir des salaires alors
je prends des dég et j'ouvre les
guillemets relativement élevé pour une
proportion population plus restreint que
dans d'autres pays
auquel cas ce qui ne rentre pas dans
l'entreprise parce qu'on a décidé de
payer je dis bien relativement plus cher
qu'ailleurs il reste un stock de
personnes toujours avec des guillemets
pardon qui sont rémunérés socialement
auquel cas il ya l'entreprise qui
supportent pour des relevés à peu près à
peu près convenable dit on et puis le
reste est pris en charge par toute la
société sur un sur le delta
dans d'autres pays on a fait d'autres
choix il ya moins de chômeurs aux états
unis oui il ya pratiquement peach up
c'est pratiquement le plein emploi en
angleterre et en allemagne simplement
est-ce qu'en france nous les prêts non
pas toucher au code du travail voire le
simplifier mais ce qu'on est prêt à des
jazz à 1 euro et où quelqu'un pourra
donner des statistiques ou y aura plus
de chômeurs effectivement je peux avec
moins de punitions les choix ccdh m
cette question si je la question du
chemin c'est pour moi la question du
choix de société ce qu'on veut que tout
le monde travaille
auquel cas ça sera des salaires qui
seront très très dégradés ou est ce
qu'on dit voilà il ya des entreprises où
les gens travaillent leur travail et
c'est plus ou moins de repérer les
autres on essaie on essaye de kef c'est
un vrai choix mais si on fait comme un
passé de ce que l'on me sens c'est ce
que veut dire ce qu'on fait comme en
angleterre des contrats trail 0 par
exemple par exemple qu'on ne peut pas se
faire les dents ça ne devrait pas
laisser notre code du zéro ça c'est pas
possible
les contrats en angleterre c'est bon
signe avec une entreprise à 0 enfin à 0
h c'est à dire que l'entraînement qu'en
entreprise a besoin de la personne puis
décroche le téléphone
j'ai besoin de vous pour une semaine
quinze jours vainqueurs 5 carats la
corse
après j'ai pu partager la tâche mais ce
que je veux dire patrice il ya deux
débats contradictoires sert qu'on veut
absolument et les politiques ont cette
pression de faire baisser la courbe du
chômage et en main en même temps
personne ne dira pour ça on est prêt à
avoir un job soit avec des contrats à
zéro à zéro heure soit des contrats un
euro de l'heure donc si ce débat sera
fait si vous avez raison monsieur moi
c'est aussi je ne vois je travaille par
contre je réclame à ce que le code du
travail soit pas un peu plus simplifiée
dans les rapports entreprises
entrepreneurs et salariés
ça pourrait mettre un peu de souplesse
et puis nous ça nous permettrait de
travailler un peu plus de 6 mais encore
une fois on a besoin de salariés pour
nos entreprises on a envie de travailler
que les uns et les autres on a besoin de
travailler collectivement
et puis alors les bonnes consciences
dont on parlait bonne conscience de
gauche comme si les mecs de gauche
n'avait pas le voix au chapitre sur
l'économie ou sur les entreprises alors
c'est vrai que de plus en plus il ya des
mecs de gauche qui donnent leur avis sur
l'entreprise
mais finalement c'est probablement le
bon sens qui l'emporté chez eux
macron que je pensais être un simple
fusil par exemple en fait c'est un
fusible sacrément résistance non mais il
faudrait avoir les 50 principes
fondamentaux donné par l'aj auxerre et
lyon caen mais renvoyé après pour le
reste à la négociation il permettre aux
entreprises qui n'ont pas de délégués du
personnel pas de délégués sur les
petites boîtes de moins de 1 des
salariés voient ou à se faire d accord
ce toit pour une fois pas les mêmes
règles
histoire de savoir combien coûte un
licenciement à terme je sais ce que ça
va me coûter je le sais je m'engage par
contre c'est à chaque fois ci c'est la
roulette
si c'est le casino cissé savoir que je
vais rentrer dans des procédures qui ont
duré quatre heures
ça va coûter jours sans combien tout à
l'heure vers la main donné il ya aussi
le fait de contrôler les indemnités sont
plafonnées maintenant l'arrêt fallu
faire ce sera chez jusque là on laisse
toujours le plancher devant lara pour
quelqu'un alors quelqu'un qui a deux ans
et deux jours va avoir droit à six mois
minimum quelqu'un qui a un an et pendant
onze mois et 29 jours lui lorsqu'il
avait fallu faire sauter le plancher il
mette un plafond un plafond ça
maintenant mais pendant venir un peu
votre question du départ je pense pas
que le code soit soit un frein à
l'embauché est un frein à l'embauché
le coût du travail le coût des charges
qui est faramineux et puis deuxièmement
d'extrêmes difficultés pour une société
à se séparer d'un salarié et ont tout à
l'heure jean-luc parler de l'exemple
allemand qui me fait pas rêver tant que
ça tous les salaires à un euro de
l'heure ce pas ça l'essentiel c'est
assez extraordinaire d'être là mais
aussi sa garantie mais aux états unis
n'ont pas à faire le reste la qualité de
la zunie on peut virer quelqu'un du jour
au lendemain les voilà maintenant ce
soir tu travailles plus et si c'est dans
les moeurs
et si on est sympa on de nuit jour
salariés ou quinze jours alors c'est un
côté ory nous en france on dit mais
c'est c'est monstrueux et cetera c'est
un truc de mais pas du tout parce
qu'aux états unis le type qui se fait
virer du journal on retrouve dès demain
matin un autre boulot parce qu'il ya
aucun frein à l'embauché de toute façon
on peut se séparer si l'un ou l'autre
deux enfants et c'est ça qui était
vraiment le vrai frein mois ci si je
je n'embauche pas par moments c'est le
coût du travail et si ça c'était on se
trompe sur un truc on n'a plus envie
faudrait s'en prennent aux on est liés à
l'or pour une grosse boîte s'est passé
c'est moins gênant parce que non mais
c'est toujours sur mes mais pour une
boîte de taille plus modeste et c'est un
truc qui peut vous mettre définitivement
à genoux donc ça c'est un véritable
frein sur ce sujet on va tous dit qu'on
passe à un autre sujet qui est celui
banal de l'acquisition de la nationalité
française droit du sol droit du sang
jusqu'à présent c'est le droit du sol
avant d'en parler je propose de voir un
sujet sur une grève d'intérimaires et
sont des sans papiers c'est une
opération coup de poing mercredi dernier
ces travailleurs sans papiers ont
investi l'agencé adecco de montigny au
coeur du problème des heures
supplémentaires ou des journées qui
resterait impayés ou encore des
certificats cerfa non délivrés
nécessaires à l'obtention des papiers
d'identité
si vous demandez notre régularisation
sans condition parce que nous habitons
tous nos droits nous remplissons les
caisses de l'état français nous payons
nos impôts
on perd deux places pour vanter la
caisse de sécurité sociale nous les
remplissons comme tous les phrases le
fond et sans le savoir un coup droit de
retour aujourd'hui vous êtes là vous
comptez rester jusqu'à quand jusqu'à ce
que nous soyons satisfaits à 100% de nos
revendications
soutenus par la cgt mais également la
ligue des droits de l'homme depuis une
semaine ces hommes vivent et dorment sur
place en attendant un rendez vous avec
la direction
cette situation de 10 des clandestins
elle perdure parce que les lois sont
faites pour ça
tant qu'on a un moyen de pression sur
des personnes quelle qu'elle soit ici
c'est à cause de leur nationalité
quand un moyen de pression va pour faire
baisser les salaires pour les mettre en
situation de précarité effectivement pas
s'étonner c'est une exploitation pour
sortir de cette situation il n'y a pas
36 solutions il n'y a qu'une c'est
l'égalité
un problème qui se généralise dans les
agences d'intérim pour le moment aucune
rencontre n'est encore prévue avec
adecco dans les yvelines deuxième agence
à poissy est également
et depuis mercredi voilà sans papiers
qu'il faut grève ce qui veut dire qu'on
peut voir son papier peut-être
revendiquer ce qui est quand même 17 pas
toujours un peu un peu invraisemblable
mais qu'est-ce que j'ai pas bien compris
si les sans-papiers qui travaillent
oui mais les dons qu'il travaille
officiellement après le non mais ça a
toujours été évident et c'est dans les
astres devant le restaurant sans papiers
en grève
c'est toujours parlé un peu à peu à même
d'aider des choses quelque chose elle
énonçait même du truc pose problème ça
va tout le monde vous dit oui pas de
place pour les âmes y en a mais pas tant
mieux mais tant mieux pour eux tant
mieux je me suis radié sur avis du
boulanger me demande je ne mentionne pas
une cause à effet par rapport aux sujets
précédent faire qu'on a des entreprises
qui payent des salaires mirobolants puis
finalement ça serait finalement le biais
que l'émigration apporte des gens qui
souhaitent qu'ils seraient moins bien
payés ou moins bien regardant voir des
gens qui seraient quasiment son contrat
de travail auquel cas ça serait une
manière de voir des charges ou des
salaires moins important à payer c'est
une question que je passais le patronat
au départ qu'on n'ait pas évolué
d'immigration pour avoir laissé la fin
du monde à dubaï avec ses 5 ans et sa
famille ont passé non c'était communiste
à lisbonne que vous donnez des cas
extrêmement concret excusez moi d'abord
vous avez beaucoup de personnes issues
de l'immigration qui se passe avec des
fausses cartes ou la carte de leurs
clients leurs cousines ça pose un vrai
problème
à partir du moment où ils ont un contrat
de travail et je parle sous le contrôle
de maître et la regarder évidemment
qu'il ya une fiche de paie ils sont
déclarés pour l'entreprise ils sont des
gens parfaitement en règle
sauf que les papiers sont pas bons à
partir de là et c'est le cas d'ailleurs
d'une partie de ces garçons ils disent
mais ça va pas moi j'ai un job je paie
des cotisations sociales etc et bon bah
oui effectivement c'est pas des bons
papiers mais aidez moi en avoir est bon
alors effectivement très très souvent ça
pose un vrai problème
la préfecture celle des yvelines toutes
les préfectures jolie sont beaucoup plus
regardantes sur le sujet mais en même
temps vous avez dans le bâtiment et les
travaux publics
et vous avez dans le domaine de la
restauration des vrais besoins d'emplois
que
trouvons pas collaborateurs et ça c'est
valable pour la région parisienne mais
c'est la loi sur tout le territoire
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est le chat
qui se mord la queue vous savez il ya un
gros problème
on parle de chômeurs 6 millions visez
vous oui c'est à peu près ça sur les
chômeurs et les précaires
mais il ya aussi huit cent mille postes
qui sont pas pourvus en france et vous
avez des quantités de d'affaires
resteront hotel paris réels intérêts 16
qui n'honore qui ferment des rangs qui
ferment des étages d'hôtel parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de femme de chambre par un
plongeur pas de serveur pas cuisiner
c'est un vrai problème marché mondial
grâce à sa vie micro d'allociné non
c'est pas vrai mais non il y en a bien
sûr qui en a mais c'est pas l'exception
qui fait un énorme et donc j'ai laissé
ma soeur et ils le sont mais chacun
cherche à être aux règles et c'est bien
normal bien sûr maintenant la règle est
tellement complexe qu'effectivement il
ya une difficulté il faut libérer un peu
travailler maintenant c'est vrai que
dans les gens qu'ils sont inverse des
mouvements il ya du bon et du moins bon
non mais il ya une chose en tout cas
dont il faut tenir compte bien sûr que
le front national défend l'idée que plus
on l'a d'immigrés puis les salaires
baissent mais c'est pas la vérité la
vérité c'est plutôt celle que donne est
toute à leur chant charles nous avons
besoin de recruter des gens et la
problématique effectivement du coût du
travail n'est pas à confondre avec le
salaire moi les gens que j'emploie ont
des salaires des salaires nets bien trop
insuffisant pour leur permettre de vivre
convenablement
par contre nous avons des charges
sociales beaucoup trop élevé alors je me
rappelle que mustapha il ya quatre
semaines les humides et vous comprenez
les médicaments la prise en charge
médicale le médecin
ça coûte beaucoup d'argent mais je pense
que nous sommes maintenant à une période
où il va falloir réviser tous à remettre
tout ça d'aplomb et ça nécessite des
réformes importantes et les réformettes
pour lesquelles on nous bassine avec les
médias depuis deux mois sont pas à la
hauteur de ce que ce pays a besoin donc
d'avoir juste terminer ma phrase on les
craint jean luc l'armée japonaise
la salle à l'argument que
j'évoquais n'est pas celui du front
national s'était même pas quand le parti
comme il le disait déjà je n'aimerais
pas que ce soit non plus l'alpha et
l'oméga chaque fois qu'on dit quelque
chose c'est même si le front national
l'a dit alors nous serions taxé d'être
probablement partisans de leur thèse
c'est parce que je vois les salaires
c'est parce que je voulais dire ce que
vous dire c'est que nous tout simplement
une grosse grosse hypocrisie encore une
fois c'est que dans les années 40-50 ce
pays était à reconstruire les émigrés
sont venus dans une vague d'émigration
qui est celle de mes parents tout
simplement et de mes parents en
l'occurrence mais de beaucoup d'autres
il n'était pas tout seul et on a
perpétré ce mouvement parce qu'à un
moment donné il ya eu il ya un besoin et
tout le monde recherche le rapport
qualité prix
comme tu recherches le rapport qualité
pour rechercher le cas le rapport qui a
été pris dans d'autres secteurs
d'activité j'ai l'impression que c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a fait mais c'est encore
pour ça qu'on continue à le faire sauf
qu'on ne le dit plus c'est à dire et
bonbons c'est quoi le rapport et le
rapport qualité prix j'entendais dans
les propos acerbes eu des abus dans les
précédents les propos de jean-luc tout
le monde a envie d'être régularisés bah
ouais moi j'ai envie dire que tout le
monde avait envie d'avoir une vie digne
c'est à dire avoir un travail avoir une
famille comme pu le faire où mon père ou
tousser mais c'est tout ce qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure et ces dames
donc c'est pas tellement envie d'être
régularisés c'est d'avoir une vie allez
on va dire confortable et régulière ça
passe pas la régularisation
oui sauf que il ya une chose qu'on omet
de dire c'est que vous disiez tout à
l'heure ils ont des fiches de paye tard
là il parle en tête c'est pas ça mange
pas je dis qu'ils sont probablement pas
payer de la même façon que les autres et
c'est ce coût du travail diminue et
parce que je ne sais pas de combien on
parle sur ses fiches de paye denture
puisque vous avant par on peut
d'ailleurs on parle je dis que c'est un
peuple malien c'est probablement un peu
un peu plus les salaires concevoir tard
je reçois ça arrive ça je paye bien mes
collaborateurs et collaboratrices et le
soleil sont stables je pose simplement
des questions je dis simplement que
quand on dit ces gens là ont des fiches
de paye et ils sont
entre guillemets à régulariser moi c'est
la question que je pense c'est au niveau
du taux horaire le côté malléable dans
les forces pour les équipes qu'on a à
exploiter aussi sa touche pas facile à
dire quand c'est pas facile j'étais hors
de moi je suis contre un tarif au
vainqueur oui tu as more about a
démissionné des papiers qui soit vrai il
faut se dire que l'employeur lui il
considère que peu de la pièce d'identité
est bonne et il paye ainsi de lier ou
dans les entreprises
c'est exact mais je ne suis pas
convaincu que ce qui fait que ceux qui
utilisent cette menace pas les nôtres
c'est très bien que le tracé de ce havre
ac il ya des salaires et les emplois
qu'il sait qu'il ya des enfants qui
n'est toujours pas et de vie patrice va
au delà des simples entreprises et
entrepreneurs parce qu'au bout de la
chaîne il ya un destructeur de valeur
il ya un client qui veut payer la main
sur au moins cher donc j'en ai tous
engagés à une course contre la montre
les prix et chacun essaie de trouver des
méthodes l'émigration en est une encore
une fois c'est pas politique ce que je
dis c'est très économiques de très près
par contre c'est un choix un choix de
société le choix de cet essai de la
politique sur justin peut-être avant de
revenir à la nationalité française
ce que vous avez vu le jour la
proposition de jean pierre raffarin
ancien premier ministre qui est dit à
baho pas tout puisqu'on va avoir une
vague d'immigration qui va venir et
probablement et dont et qu'il faudra
bien un petit peut accueillir pourquoi
on ne ferait pas revivre des villages
qui sont abandonnés qui n'existe plus
qu'ils vivent plus grâce à cette
immigration qu est ce que vous pensez va
se dessiner autour du village déjà pour
payet il peut y avoir de son village de
pouvoir vous faire revivre le village du
cheval
alors les hommes troncs charges sociales
on a déjà essayé les zones franches
c'est sympa donné de résultat c'est
vraiment un
donc les villages faut quand même bien
sûr que nous pouvons faire occuper des
villages par détermine ses parents il va
falloir qu'il ya du boulot à côté c'est
tout si c'est pour les prendre en charge
leur donner le village
je vois pas très bien l'intérêt je
comprendrais pas l'idée est magnifique
après effectivement faut voir comment
ses finances et après on peut aussi se
dire que quitte à financer quelqu'un
autant le financer dans une maison dans
un village et ça va sauver l'école ça va
sauver la boulangerie ça va sauver le
petit bureau de poste que de savoir qui
va s'entasser qui vont s'entasser dans
un une cité petit le mans sordide et
toucher les mêmes émoluments
donc voilà ça c'est déjà une chose qu'il
quitte à toucher une aide ou temps la
toussaint dans un endroit en riant et
qui que l'on puisse en avoir un petit
intérêt non après l'autre question que
ça peut poser c'est aussi si on fait ça
pour les migrants et c'est très bien et
c'est très noble c'est une très belle
idée de rafah pourquoi ne pas le faire
et le proposer à des gens qui ne
seraient pas des migrants mais des
français classique et qui sont dans à
peu près dans la zone dont la sécurité
dans la même à sécurité est dans le même
malaise que les gens en difficulté a
voulu faire la même pour des stations
disant écoutez il a entendu à la radio
la semaine dernière un village qui a
proposé qu avait mis la vente d'un
terrain à l'euro les ont valu d'être
carré pour faire venir des familles
faire revivre notre mouvement parce que
la vente d'un terrain à 1 euro le mètre
carré
il faut quand même après rajouter 150000
euros pour y faire construire sa maison
donc si tu veux c'est pas une anémie
grande base oui mais c'était le village
bamena dans cette france en france elle
même il ya beaucoup de tentatives de
danseuse dans ce cadre-là du noyonnais
d'emploi de l'une des choses les ennemis
les mairies achète les commerces et nous
à des sommes modiques à des gens moi je
le disais simplement qu'on pouvait il ya
quand même toute une population à sorte
d'aucune sorte de quart monde français
qui seraient peut-être très contents
qu'on leur propose aussi c'est ce qui
plaît de des migrations à la campagne
c'est ce que dit ''très était dans mon
paradis c'est une question proportions
et pas d'envoyer 50 migrants dans un
dans ma villa mais une famille vivent
les familles qui puisse me faire
attaquer et quelquefois ça suffit à
faire basculer pour garder l'école
ouverte
ça me fait penser un peu à l'invention
du fil à couper le beurre a quand même
la chance la plupart du temps pas la vie
de village se sont désertifier parce que
l'entreprise la petite usine qui avait à
côté est parti quand on a laissé à
vau-l'eau aller les routes parce qu'il
n'y a plus de train on a viré la gare
parce qu'elle-même plus de lignes de car
voilà et donc du coup le village ap
personne dedans alors si on veut
remettre des gens dedans
la première des choses c'est de savoir
si on les havrais les malfaçons
subventionnés ou bien si on fait en
sorte qu'à partager ses brûlures bien
sûr puisse être autosuffisants ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'évidemment
derrière la mise en place de famille
dans ces villages qu'elle vienne de
france quart monde etc ou de l'étranger
et bien parfait à condition de pouvoir
redonner du travail des transports et un
cadre de vie qui soit effectivement
convenable est propice à un bon
développement des familles mais ça
passera un parent vraiment tout ça s'est
pas arrangée par certificat avec la même
somme
une enveloppe de 5 à 1000 euros pour une
famille dans la région parisienne tu ne
vis pas à la campagne tu lis très bien
et d'accords otages étaient trois poules
contre uc études et merde c'est pas le
paradis mais voilà il ya il faut aussi
prendre sans compter qu'il ya des choses
possibles dont quelques unes en droit
français région qui voit là je pense que
ces dix seront ils sont contents je
pense que monsieur raphaël aura
peut-être essayer de trouver avec
quelques détails à sa façon pour jean
pierre raffarin vient du poitou alors un
mot sur la le code de la nationalité
je disais c'est le droit du sol vous
avez raison de de préciser que c'est un
mix entre le droit du sol droit du sang
vous nous préciser un petit peu ce que
ce qui est de nationalité aujourd'hui et
qu'elle est la réforme que veulent faire
les républicains notamment nicolas
sarkozy je comprends pas très bien enfin
on reviendra sur nicolas sarkozy mais il
ya dix radicalement inverse
quel sens que l'actuel m'en sépare
actuellement manhwa bon c'est le droit
du sang s'est dès lors qu'un enfant né
d'un des deux parents qui est français
s'est lancé et français ça c'est la
partie droit du sang déclinée sur le sol
des guinées sur le sol français à partir
du moment où il a deux parents
l'étranger s'ils né sur le sol français
de parents étrangers
dès lors que il a cinq ans de résidence
après l'âge de 11 ans dès lors qu'il a
cinq ans de résidence continue sur le
sol français il peut à sa majorité
enfin aujourd'hui c'est automatique il a
la nationalité en france
automatiquement français à moi il
fallait demander se passe quoi il
fallait qu'ils fassent la demande et
qu'ils soient pro actif dans le domaine
des lois nationales
il m'a lancé c'est automatique
voilà ce que vous la base le martyre va
je dispose pas de ce que propose au rang
des bars
le parti je crois que ce que propose le
parti républicain est ce que propose
sarkozy c'est peut-être mal dit mal
exprimé en tout cas à l'évidence mal
compris mais c'est surtout que derrière
cette idée et l'idée c'est de dire la
nationalité française c'est une joie
c'est un plaisir c'est quelque chose
qu'on devrait le monde y était et
demandé et c'est pas quelque chose là
automatisé de renouveau tout le monde se
vouer
l'idée c'est de dire on devrait arrêter
de critiquer la france de dire que les
français sont des pourris que la france
est un pays de merde et qu'en même temps
après mais on veut bien être
ontex automatique d'être français c'est
simplement ça ce que veut le parti
républicain c'est dire qu'il voulait
être français soyez fiers des français
il est mort dès lors de ce que vous
parlait français ça pourrait être un
plus parce que c'est vrai que c'est plus
facile pour s'intégrer
ce qui paraît pas complètement idiot
comme d'état de pays je dire aux états
unis le dire ou là il fit donner aux
états unis on est américain on demande
quand même un examen il faut être
capable de citer 30 des présidents
américains
quand même bon je veux dire je suis
franc présidence française je vous donne
mon billet que personne très peu de deux
postulants n'incite les français
seraient capables de citer quatre
présidents de la vème république
bon vous posez la question à des jeunes
français
mais ils n'y seraient pas aimé que tu
m'aies loi sur la faillite de
l'éducation nationale ça c est une autre
chose
mais fin on devrait on devrait pouvoir
citer les cinq présidents de la v qui
veulent que les français qui acquiert la
société par le droit du sol c'est dire
automatiquement s'ils sont restés plus
de cinq ans à partir de 11 ans comme des
influences et à le demander un petit
examen bandits dont je suis content
j'aimerais de france elle s'est fait
ravir
c'est pas une remise en cause du droit
du sol mais c'est un aménagement et
c'est simplement transmis leurs gardes
voilà roulant passoire ce que t'es pas
passer pas aberrant moi si je voulais
être américain ça me choquerait pas de
demandes émanent ociété américain où ça
va se passer
vous avez une expérience là dessus j'ai
une expérience mais j'ai l'expérience de
migrants
de nassim de naturalisation de
nationalisation puisque paraît-il
effectivement je suis né français
puisque né en 61 2 par an la france est
à versailles donc 61 droit le droit du
sol avec des parents donc qu'ils étaient
français également puisque deux
départements français
l'algérie oui oui la vérité frais louise
donc en 60 2 donc j'ai un nom je deviens
donc algérien au 1er janvier 63 pardon
je deviens algérien puisque le
département français est décolonisé
devient l'algérie où je deviens algérien
et ensuite c'est à la majorité que
revient le droit comme c'est de proposer
aujourd'hui le droit à l'époque c'était
donc à la demande
chacun devra en faire la demande chacun
devait faire un peu voilà un examen de
conscience pour se dire finalement je
suis au en termes de nationalité et est
donc redevenir français sauf que moi
donc je suis nouvellement s'amender moi
je suis français j'ai demandé et c'est
une réintégration qu'on a proposé donc
c'est encore une subtilité
une subtilité toujours toujours
particulier vous le savez ce que je vois
cette émission et que les
téléspectateurs ne regarde de données
donc voilà il faut poser des questions
sur les marges devraient revenir quand
même sur ce que dit jean charles
non non c'est un rendez vous parce que
c'est comme ça wilzig se trouve
maintenant c'est vrai que arrivé en tant
qu au moment où je je je choisis donc
l'année c'était française
c'est vrai que les caisses des vrais
villages j'avais donc 28 ans à 50 ans
parce que vous vouliez devenir
pharmacien française est en fait la
question qui m'est posée c'est de savoir
si je me sens français donc je répond
naturellement oui sauf que je comprends
pas bien la question comme je comprends
pas bien ce que dit jean charles ce que
disent certaines personnes je comprends
pas bien je suis français mais s'il faut
que je le proclame
je veux bien le faire je vois pas
pourquoi je me j'en serais obligé comme
pourrait le faire
nos deux amis nos trois amis dont quatre
animateurs de cette table on vous le
demande pas à vous on en est convaincu
on me demanderait à moi on me
dray bon après tout si on me demande
chez l'exercice après tout je suis en
capacité de le faire ça ne pose aucun
problème mais quand même ça m'interroge
parce que à cette question vous sentez
vous êtes là j'ai répondu ouais je me
sens bien français 6 6 et 6 et boire un
coup samedi à boire un petit coup de
rouge ça m'est déjà arrivé je dis ça et
je salue tous ceux qui font le ramadan
pendant que pendant qu'on discute
en l'occurrence c'est juste pour dire
que c'est arrivé effectivement je puisse
pratiquer des us et coutumes sauf que
pour moi les us et coutumes sont une
caractéristique de là on va dire de la
culture d'un pays pas forcément de sa
nationalité ou de son drapeau et à ce
moment là il me dit mais mais mais
encore
moi j'écoute et je prépare une thèse une
thèse donc un doctorat avec une thèse en
pharmacie et je suis obligé de le
corriger puisque il écrivait
effectivement selon lui le raid n'est
pas l'opus et coutumes et la thèse d'un
z je suis obligé de corriger le le
préposé même la personne va maintenant
commencer
c'est anecdotique simplement on voit
bien qui fait son boulot de vérification
en fait c'est ça l'idée on vérifie alors
il ya probablement d'autres manières de
vérifier probablement donc maintenant de
vérifier mais à mon sens pas forcément
le bachotage j'ai fait j'ai fait une
thèse et j'ai possédé matière ouais j'ai
su ça par coeur le site de crêpes c'est
un peu plus compliqué que de retenir les
50 derniers présidents des républiques
françaises
je pense que le bachotage quelqu'un qui
va faire l'effort d'apprendre quelque
chose parce qu'il sait que ça sera la
question cruciale va le faire et pour
autant il en sera pas donc ça ce bel
effort s'adresse à qui l'afer se mérite
et ça se mérite simplement le mairie
qu'il est toujours
il est toujours dans les deux sens est
ce que vous trouvez cela j'ai vraiment
le sentiment d'un peuple uni en vo vous
redire les sourds âge c'est probablement
pas le mot parce que c'est tout aussi
violent que de dire que c'est humiliant
après tout un pays peut mettre des
droits comme il peut mettre des devoirs
mais ses devoirs après tout quand on
connaît la règle on s'y plie parce que
c'est un devoir donc c'est pas forcément
humiliant il ya une règle et on la
respecte simplement avant que les droits
soient écrits et avant d'y répondre
on peut peut-être discuter ensemble de
la manière dont on va imposer cette
règle qui s'imposera forcément à tous
sans que ça devienne une humiliation
comme elles sont
discutez ccoc exactement comme quand on
a fait quand on a fait une erreur de
faire rentrer natoye de travail quel
pays dans leurs options on n'aurait pas
d'avocat non les deux comparses et sa
dictature ce nom un an et demi ont servi
aux pays européens qui voulaient nous
rejoindre voilà les lois de l'europe
sont celles ci ça vous intéresse vous
venez ça vous intéresse pas vous venez
pas dire non plus un seul à prendre la
pelle resteront à fédérer tous les pays
qui voulaient rentrer si éventuellement
le martial et de la façon de gouverner
l'europe lorsque les excès et là c'est
pareil c'est pas une sentinelle français
on va pas te demander de mai chez
duceppe accusé de la façon dont tu sais
pas d'où ça c'est parce que je dis c'est
pas de la question n'est pas de savoir
si je veux être franc c'est le gazon
c'est je suis français des textes
parlent de latex et des règles c'est la
vérification
j'aimerais que cette vérification soient
soumises et qu'elles soient probables
amendé c'est que les banques sans que ça
soit fait une thèse de pharmacie donc tu
dis que c'est plus compliqué une telle
réforme ainsi que d'apprendre le nom de
nom des présidents de la république tu
as sûrement raison
mais tout le monde n'a pas le ton niveau
intellectuel et de niveau universitaire
donc c'est pas un argument on peut
simplement exigé que les gens qui
veulent être français en expriment le
désir mais tu vas y at il une amende si
simple de cabanes carte grise une carte
d'identité c'est plus important
moi je veux dire moi je suis allé le
degré important quel est le degré
d'exigence que tu pourrais obtenir pour
réellement faire d'un être les 5
essentiel
un vrai citoyen mais mois déjà que la
personne express relie en 10 ans
j'aimerais c'est vrai à paris totalement
faux et ben si ça peut déjà estimer si
on est déjà et surtout un sens à cette
idée de faussetés que les étudiants
seront détruits un citoyen mais
simplement on dit voilà on va dans une
on va dans une mairie on va dans un truc
un drapeau français il ya la vigne à la
tête du prêt à la république et on nous
dit c'est une petite ferme la lévisienne
mais voilà dans le jeu j'aimerais dire
danaher certains verraient l'idée me
plaît votants mais voilà et je signe la
science mais par avec des amis avec un
briquet dans ce domaine sont plutôt très
révélateur de l'amour qu'ils ont pour
leur pays chez les seniors il ya un
drapeau toutes les portes de maisons
bon donc chez eux il ya un vrai
sentiment d'appartenance et quelque part
ça développe un sentiment de patriotisme
les américains et
la main sur le coeur vert lime
d'american chez new line fait sifflée
dans les stades
quant au canton demande si en un maître
français on entend souvent des ballons
on s'en fout tout ça donc on aimerait
bien quelques parcs quelle que soit
l'origine des personnes interrogées
qu'ils soient d'origine bretonne ou
algérienne importe peu mais que nous
sentions vrai examen total ans à la
patrie au pays
moi ça me paraît quand même extrêmement
tout se passe comme ça mais à
l'américain c'est imprécis même un
américain récent gagner quelque chose ou
réussir quelque chose et dire non mais
je ne suis pas qu'américain je suis
aussi avant j'étais tels que jamais et
le mec il est américaine et même
l'amérique alitalia d'être américain en
france
on va d'abord on gagne au moins
effectivement mais sinon non non la
majorité des sportifs célèbres de l'armé
atomique avant de l'abattre parce que
moi ce qui me gêne pour faire simple
c'est que tout ce qui se dit autour de
cette table est vrai c'est à dire que
effectivement il ya des gens qui
sifflent d'un drapeau français
il ya des gens qu'ils en l'occurrence
qui pourrait dire des choses qui
seraient contraires ou à la république
ou voir même fonds propres citoyens de
base
c'est juste que il vous faut quelques
exemples pour élaborer ce que vous êtes
en train de dire moi je vous dis que la
majorité des gens que je côtoie avec
lesquels je vis au quotidien trappe en
particulier mais pour être né à
versailles de la même façon pour avoir
fréquenté les facultés les gens de même
nature ou des gens qui n'ont pas le même
niveau intellectuel
tous ces gens là aiment la france de la
lune laisse ma vie dans ma phrase
je suis en train de toi ça va les gêner
on sait ce que je sais ce que je vais
dire tu sais ce que je vais dire qui tu
proposes de l' inverse si tu sais ce que
je vais dire alors dit la même chose que
moi parce que je te dis que la plupart
des gens que je côtoie on va dire allez
des beurs et des blacks faire simple de
d'origine un peu diverses et d'ailleurs
je te dis qu'ils disent la même chose
que moi sans avoir le même niveau ni
intellectuel des scolaires parce que
c'est pas de ça dont il s'agit
il s'agit de coeur il s'agit de malades
de passion pour un pays ils l'ont dans
la grande majorité simplement s'il vous
faut des prétextes
vous en aurez toujours et ces prétextes
cela si vous vous les avez en
revendiquant le fait que ça peut être
une tête du front national qu'il faut
combattre
vous êtes contre dans le même camp de la
même façon le front national en fait une
thèse et ils se trompent vous
l'alimenter en faisant croire que c'est
encore vrai moi je vous le dis je côtoie
ces gens là je ne côtoie quasi mot que
ces gens là c'est pas ça par contre des
exemples vous en aurez pour dire le
contraire
j'ai juste envie vous dire s'il est bien
entendre que la majorité la très grande
majorité l'immense majorité de mes
gosses dans le foot de mes éducateurs
des gens que je côtoie aime ce pays
m7 france le 10 de la même façon que
nous aussi on a quelques-uns dans une
main et est ce que ça les aiderait fait
les gênerait au moment mais on passe qui
devrait devenir français il faisait un
petit rhume il y est né dans une mairie
qui vient j'aimerais être français
disent qu'ils sont aux grands vents et
milliers il se déclare français comme tu
laisses tu leur donnes une raison bien
sûr ils ont leur demande sur leur
deuxième phase avec des enduits là on
est en train de parler deux là qui
veulent devenir français pas de gens qui
sont français oui mais je te parle
également de se joindre à tracer les
ardennais 800 cm3 et de devenir et qui
sache en france je ne sens pas dans vos
propos vous opposer pardonnez moi qui
situe témoin ici 6 avril tous les genres
à si mustapha terrain que tous ceux
qu'il côtoie quelque chose m la france
j'ai par exemple jean charest j'aimerais
que tous aiment la france est la seule
dépense et le dire
10 l affaire il aimerait et marty cette
conversation
c'est la partie légale c'était un droit
du sang projet sol c'est de dire à
partir ce qu'il faut les agréables dire
non à l'étranger
on s'est bien relancé on en redemande eu
ça me paraît pas être complètement fou
et en tout cas ça ne mérite pas une
telle opposition
encore une fois mesdames messieurs à
cette taille en train de se construire
le mur de la dictature peut plus
discuter on doit pas avoir d' afrique
non mais sérieusement je ne dis pas que
les règles ne peuvent pas s'amuser à
tous et que tout le monde s'y pliera
puisque par définition la france est
aussi d alors pourquoi brightman demandé
à tout le monde mais dans ce cas là
pourquoi tout le monde parce que là pour
vous aider après tout elle qu'à 18 ans
n'est pas très commun de savoie et
lorsque je pose simplement à mon sens
cette fois proposer aux gens qu'ils sont
français de ne plus l'être à 8 à 18 ans
je faisais l'addition nous allons
sceller ce je ne suis pas sûr mais je ne
suis pas sûr dont certaines régions des
bretons des corses revendiquerait comme
français actuel n'y a pas encore eu
heureusement je ne verrai pas ça de
nationalité bretonne qui n'était corse
donc heureusement donc limpide le gars
vous êtes plus français vous êtes quoi
en revanche je tiens à préciser quand
même je prendrai les esteys je pense que
le noeud citoyens européens
je pense que non mais je pense que le
véritable sujet il est là en fait parce
que je crois que sur le fait qu'on soit
français ou qu'on aime la france
beaucoup à dire ça ne veut rien dire il
n'y a pas de débat
il n'y a pas de débat je pense qu'ils
sont humains je pense que ce soit aux
citoyens européens jeunes n'ont pas
vraiment avancé où je pense ce qui va
donc à mon avis le plus parce que c'est
pas tant la nation française au drapeau
français les règles françaises où la
république c'est plutôt cette idée selon
laquelle on est français mais pas tout à
fait on va on va sauter le drapeau
algérien on va sortir drapeau tunisien
ça jamais fait chier personne que des
américains français sortent de temps en
temps des drapeaux américains
je le vois
je me vois dampierre à chaque fois qu'il
ya une manifestation le super bowl les
choses comme ça c'est des drapeaux
américains déployés dans toute la
commune
bon personne ne va dire on a vu plein de
drapeaux américains sachant que - ou
d'autres drapeaux pour des allemands qui
par exemple peuvent supporter la
mannschaft laquelle je suis honnête je
suis d'accord que moi je suis honnête et
donc moi je vous lis un moment donné est
ce qu'on peut pas tout simplement
comprendre qu'il ya de l'affect aussi
chez dans un être dans un an et il ya le
raisonnement il ya le raisonner et j'ai
l'impression de l'être parfois il ya un
peu d'affect aussi et savoir qu'on est à
d'origine algérienne et aimer cette
culture et mais cette langue
aimer c'est jean aimé son numéro pas de
temps en temps ou et on se dit tiens on
est aussi un peu en appartenance comme
les bretons le fond comme les corses le
fonds maintient c'est juste que j'aurais
qu'on se détendre sur cette question on
est tous français il ya des droits et de
devoirs et tout le monde n'a jamais
personne n'a jamais dit le contraire
laisser un peu l'affect aussi remplacé
aux deux pays d'étendre le monde
la conclusion c'est qu'en fait on n'a
toujours pas digéré notre problème de
colonisation puisque un algérien n'égale
par un allemand enfin je veux dire c'est
bien ce qu'on a dit les drapeaux
allemands ça gêne pas les drapeaux
algériens sa gêne il est là c'est super
bowl uru coupe du monde où je sais pas
sûr que le nazisme n'ont pour l'instant
pas les travaux pour finir le bac pour
le supprimer ou pas non non non non non
non donc je n'en mets plus de contrôle
continu
ok merci à tous les clubs on en
reparlera pas ce que c'était c'était
cette sorte de passage obligatoire voilà
voilà voilà faire l'âne résultat le
paquet ça qui avait lieu cette semaine
on en reparlera peut-être la semaine
prochaine on se retrouve de toute façon
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
pape
merci à tous